Hey there, everybody. Ira Glass here. So our show today is something that producer Chana Joffe-Walt has been collaborating on with reporter Nikole Hannah-Jones. And Nikole's version of the story, which is in The New York Times Magazine, is something that many, many people are discussing online right now.
大家好，我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目内容是由制作人查娜·乔菲-沃尔特与记者妮可·汉娜-琼斯合作完成的。妮可撰写的报道刊登在《纽约时报杂志》上，目前在网上引起了许多人的讨论。
And I just want to say that if you have seen that article, there are a lot of things in what you're about to hear that are not in the article. Particularly, you'll get to hear at length from Nikole's daughter. And there are things that commenters are raising online that get interestingly addressed in our version.
我想说的是，如果你已经读过那篇文章，接下来的节目里会有很多文章中未曾提及的内容。特别是，你们将听到妮可女儿的详细叙述。而且，网上评论者提出的某些问题，在我们的版本中也得到了有趣的解答。
If you have no idea what I'm talking about, don't worry. All of this will become clear. And with that, here's Chana Joffe-Walt talking with Nikole Hannah-Jones. These are recordings made as Nikole was in the process of writing that article.
如果你不知道我在说什么，不用担心，所有这些都会明朗起来。接下来是查娜·乔菲-沃尔特与妮可·汉娜-琼斯的对话。这些录音是在妮可撰写那篇文章的过程中录制的。
I'm going to make sure we're recording.
我要确保我们在录音。
All right.
好的。
Has it been 10 years since you've been in here?
你已经有10年没来这里了吧？
I'm trying to think when-- I'm like, damn. I know it's been a long time. How long has it been?
我在想那是什么时候……该死。我知道已经很久了。到底多久了？
That's Nikole. And this is a ritual I find myself in with some frequency at my age-- beginning social interactions with an accounting of time that inevitably leads to a conversation about the kids, where they were then and where they are now.
那是妮可。这个仪式我在这个年纪经常进行——在社交开始时，先核对一下时间，这不可避免地会引出关于孩子的话题，谈论他们过去在哪，现在又在哪。
And my child was just getting ready to start school. And now my child is a sophomore getting ready to celebrate her sweet 16.
那时我的孩子刚准备上学。现在她已经是十年级生，准备庆祝16岁生日了。
That is wild.
那太疯狂了。
确实疯狂。
Really, 16?
真的，16岁了？
She will be 16 next month. Yeah, time.
她下个月就16岁了。是啊，时间过得真快。
Nikole and I spent a lot of time talking about our kids 10 years ago and talking about schools. We were reporting together on education, specifically on inequality and systemic racism in American public schools-- how decades of policy choices have left public schools deeply unequal, many schools completely neglected. And meanwhile, Nikole and I had little kids. And in our own lives, the conversation among parents was how to game the system to be sure that your children do not end up in one of those schools.
10年前，我和妮可花了很多时间讨论我们的孩子和学校。我们当时一起报道教育问题，特别是美国公立学校中的不平等和系统性种族主义——几十年的政策选择如何导致公立学校极度不平等，许多学校完全被忽视。与此同时，妮可和我都还带着年幼的孩子。在我们自己的生活中，家长们谈论的话题总是如何钻系统的空子，确保自己的孩子不会去那些学校。
Literally every middle-class parent, no matter what their race was, was like, you have to put her in talented and gifted prep courses because they test at four. And you have to decide if you're going to put her in private school. But you're definitely not going to put her in the neighborhood school. And I lived in the heavily Black, high-poverty neighborhood.
真的，每一位中产阶级家长，无论什么种族，都会说：“你得让她参加天才预科班，因为他们四岁就开始测试了。”你得决定是否要送她去私立学校。但你绝对不会让她去社区学校。而我当时就住在黑人聚居、贫困率很高的社区。
These questions, what are you going to do about school, started right out of the gate.
这些关于“你打算怎么处理上学问题”的疑问，从一开始就出现了。
I mean, my response was, she's one. And people would look at me like, oh, you're so naive. I remember people being like, you silly woman. And people actually felt that that was not being a good parent, frankly.
我的回答是，她才一岁。人们看着我，就好像在说，“哦，你太天真了。”我记得有人说，“你这傻女人。”坦白说，人们甚至觉得那样做不是个好家长。
This intense, often judgmental scramble is something parents in places all over America do. But in New York City where Nikole and I live, it's arguably the most extreme version. Parents have spreadsheets of schools, endless advice. You're going to want to avoid this school. Apply to this program. Maybe move to a different neighborhood.
这种激烈且往往带有评判意味的争抢，是美国各地家长都会做的事。但在我和妮可居住的纽约市，这可以说是最极端的版本。家长们手握学校列表，听着没完没了的建议：“你肯定想避开这所学校”、“申请这个项目吧”、“也许搬到另一个社区去”。
Any contortion makes sense, not even to strive for an elite school, but to avoid a, quote, "bad school." What were the bad schools? Well, New York City has one of the most racially and economically segregated school systems in the country. The, quote, "bad schools" that families with options tried to avoid were disproportionately Black, Latino, and poor. In her reporting, Nikole had seen that Black students all over the country are concentrated in schools like this, where they're less likely to have the best teachers or curricula or facilities. And one reason that happens is that wealthy and middle-class families, like hers, opt out of those schools.
任何变通手段似乎都有道理，不是为了进入精英学校，而是为了避开所谓的“烂学校”。什么是烂学校呢？纽约市拥有全国种族和经济隔离程度最高的学校系统之一。那些有条件的家庭试图避开的所谓“烂学校”，往往以黑人、拉丁裔和贫困学生为主。妮可在报道中发现，全国各地的黑人学生都集中在这样的学校里，他们获得最好的教师、课程或设施的机会较少。这种情况发生的原因之一，就是像她那样的富裕和中产阶级家庭选择退出这些学校。
So Nikole, who had a young Black daughter and had been a young Black girl herself, when her daughter Najya got to be school aged, she did not make a spreadsheet. She did not game the system. She enrolled Najya in a regular public school, the kind of school most New York City kids end up in. The students mostly came from the neighborhood, Black and Latino kids, poor and working class.
所以，妮可作为一个有年幼黑人女儿的黑人母亲，当她的女儿纳贾到了上学年龄时，她没有制作表格，也没有去钻系统的空子。她让纳贾进入了一所普通的公立学校，那是大多数纽约孩子最终会去的学校。学生大部分来自社区，包括黑人、拉丁裔、贫困和工薪阶层家庭的孩子。
Here's how Nikole saw it. She thought if more parents with advantage like her are inside a school, they could add their weight. They'll be personally invested. They'll be paying attention and seeing when there are problems. They can advocate for a school for funding, for more experienced teachers, for extra programming so all the students in the school, including their own kids, have what they need to learn.
妮可是这样看的。她认为，如果更多像她一样拥有资源的家长进入学校，他们就能增加话语权。他们会投入个人精力，保持关注，并在出现问题时及时发现。他们可以为学校争取资金、更有经验的老师和额外的课程，这样学校里的所有学生，包括他们自己的孩子，都能获得学习所需的资源。
Nikole wrote about all this in a cover story for The New York Times Magazine 10 years ago. And on the cover there was little Najya in her school uniform, afro puffs, serious face looking right at the camera, and the headline--
10年前，妮可在《纽约时报杂志》的封面文章中写到了这一切。封面上是穿着校服、扎着非洲小辫、神情严肃注视着镜头的纳贾，标题是——
"Choosing a School for my Daughter in a Segregated City."
“在一个种族隔离的城市，为女儿选择学校。”
I remember seeing it.
我记得看到过那篇报道。
So that's the setup.
这就是背景。
I remember seeing it and being like, oh, she did it.
我记得当时看到的时候心想：天哪，她真的这么做了。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, because you and I, we talked a lot about it.
是的，是的，因为你和我当时讨论过很多次。
It was an earthquake of a story, Nikole putting the matter bluntly to parents. All of us gaming the system is making the system worse. What if we just stop?
那篇报道就像地震一样，妮可直言不讳地指出：我们所有人在钻系统空子，反而让系统变得更糟。如果我们停止这样做会怎样？
I was really, really shocked by the impact that this piece had. People were both writing, but also just sharing their story with me at my public speeches or other events that I was giving, like face to face, which was extremely powerful for me as well.
那篇文章产生的影响让我非常、非常震惊。人们不仅给我写信，还在我的公开演讲或其他活动中当面分享他们的故事，这对我来说力量极其强大。
I feel like you're underselling how much influence this had on--
我觉得你低估了这件事的影响力……
Am I? What am I supposed to say?
是吗？我该怎么说呢？
So there's school districts across the country that were suddenly talking about something that they had not been talking about-- not just parents, but actual people controlling school policy.
全国各地的学区突然开始谈论他们以前从不触碰的话题——不仅是家长，还有真正掌控学校政策的人。
Yes. In some ways, this was my dream as a journalist. I became a writer because I wanted society to change. So I always write in a way where I'm trying to persuade people by making a moral argument.
是的。在某些方面，这是我作为记者的梦想。我成为作家是因为我想改变社会。所以我写的每一篇文章，都是试图通过道德论证来说服人们。
That's what the story was, an argument, and it landed with so many people.
那篇故事就是这样一个论点，它触动了很多人。
This story just, in some ways, never lost its legs. I was in Boston a few weeks ago, and a woman who has a six-year-old-- her child wasn't even born when the story came out-- said that this story guided her education decision making for her child.
这篇报道在某种程度上从未失去热度。几周前我在波士顿，一位六岁孩子的母亲——她的孩子在文章发表时甚至还没出生——告诉我，这篇报道指导了她为孩子做出教育选择。
In a lot of your events, there were some people who would come up to you to absolve them of the choice that they had made.
在你参加的许多活动中，有些人走近你是为了让你赦免他们所做的选择。
Oh, all the time. Almost every public event I would do, either during the question and answer session after the event, they would corner you. And there would inevitably be a parent or parents who would explain why they really, really, really believed in what I was saying, and they believed in the power of equality, but they couldn't make that choice for whatever reason.
哦，总是这样。几乎我参加的每一场公开活动，在问答环节或者活动结束后，他们都会把我围住。必然会有家长解释为什么他们非常、非常相信我说的内容，他们相信平等的力量，但因为各种原因他们做不到那个选择。
And I'd always be like, OK. I'm not your priest. I cannot absolve you, and I don't want to absolve you. I wanted you to be forced to be like, what about these kids? What do they deserve?
我总是说：好吧，我不是你的牧师，我不能赦免你，我也不想赦免你。我希望你被强迫思考：那些孩子呢？他们应得的是什么？
So for 10 years, Nikole has talked publicly all over the country about every aspect of this article except how it played out in her own life for her and her kid. And she decided she wanted to write about what happened and talk through it. So, many months ago, Nikole reached out to me to ask if I wanted to hear everything that happened after the article was published.
所以这10年来，妮可在全国各地公开讨论了这篇文章的方方面面，除了它在现实生活中对自己和孩子产生的影响。她决定写下后来发生的事情并进行讨论。几个月前，妮可联系我，问我是否想听听文章发表后发生的一切。
Yes, I did. She thought all the people who read her original essay 10 years ago and thought about it and talked to her about it and passed it on to others deserved to know how it actually turned out. And she thought her daughter, Najya, deserved a chance to share her perspective too.
是的，我想听。她认为所有在10年前读过那篇原创文章、思考过、讨论过并将它转发给他人的人，都理应知道结局如何。她认为她的女儿纳贾也理应有机会分享她的观点。
Najya was eager to talk. She had a lot she wanted to say about this. And she has a very different take from her mom's. What you're going to hear is a series of conversations that took place before Nikole published her recent New York Times article as she was trying to figure out in real time what she would write about all this.
纳贾很乐意谈论这件事。她有很多想说的话，而且她的看法与母亲截然不同。你接下来听到的是一系列对话，发生于妮可发表最近那篇《纽约时报》文章之前，当时她正试图实时厘清自己要写什么。
I talked to Nikole, and later I talked to Najya, and she talks to her mom. These are our conversations throughout which I was so alert and on edge sometimes. It is rare to hear a person who made a big, influential argument come forward and say, honestly, this is how it actually played out, and then publicly face their teenager. Who subjects themselves to that?
我和妮可谈过，后来又和纳贾谈过，她也和她妈妈聊了。这些是我们之间的对话，过程中我有时非常警觉且紧张。很少能听到一个提出重大且有影响力观点的人站出来说：“诚实地说，事情实际是这样发展的”，然后公开面对自己的青少年孩子。谁会让自己经历这种场面？
That's today's show, "An Argument" in five acts, two people willing to talk about some of the country's most enduring problems and look at how they unfolded in their own lives as mother and daughter. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. Stay with us.
这就是今天的节目，分五幕的“一个论点”，两个愿意谈论国家最持久问题的母女，审视这些问题在她们自己生活中如何演变。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》。请继续收听。
It's This American Life, Act One-- Nikole's Choice. Nikole had been the one to pick the school back when Najya was little. Her husband, Faraji, had been reluctant to send Najya there. He worried they'd be hurting her, asked Nikole, is this us experimenting on our child based on idealism? They'd argued about it.
这是《美国生活》，第一幕——妮可的选择。当初是妮可选择了那所学校。她的丈夫法拉吉起初很勉强，担心这对纳贾会有伤害，问妮可：这是否基于理想主义而拿孩子做实验？他们为此争论过。
But once they resolved to do it, Faraji was all in. He threw himself into the school. Both of them were committed to being involved, and Faraji ended up even more involved than Nikole. They reassured themselves, knowing that if there were ways the school fell short, they could get Najya help, and they'd be there watching. They were both constantly assessing how it was going, where the school faltered, where it succeeded, what Najya was getting. They were tracking all of it, including benefits that don't get factored into lists of New York City's top schools.
但一旦决定了，法拉吉就全身心投入。他们承诺积极参与，法拉吉甚至比妮可投入更多。他们安慰自己，知道如果有学校做得不足的地方，他们可以为纳贾争取帮助，并且会一直在那关注。他们不断评估进展、学校哪里做得好、哪里失败、纳贾获得了什么。他们追踪着一切，包括那些在纽约顶级学校列表中无法体现的益处。
She got to spend her first six years of education in a school where most of the kids look like her, where she had incredible Black and-- she had a Chinese American educator. She had incredible Black educators. She had Caribbean educators. Amazing Black History Month celebrations.
她在那里度过了最初的六年教育，学校里大多数孩子长得像她，她有很棒的黑人……还有一位华裔美国教育工作者。她有杰出的黑人教师，有来自加勒比地区的老师。还有很棒的“黑人历史月”庆祝活动。
They used to have the students do these self-portraits. And she would always when she was young make herself a dark-skinned Black woman, which I was like, yes, so you are, as a Black girl, seeing yourself in that lens and not in the lens of this outside world that is saying that that's not beautiful or that's not something to aspire to. And so in her formative years, she didn't have that experience that I had of feeling less than other kids, of feeling like, is there something wrong with Black people, feeling different. She didn't have that.
他们以前会让学生画自画像。她小时候总是把自己画成一个深肤色的黑人女性，我心想：太棒了。作为黑人女孩，你从那个视角看待自己，而不是通过外界那个说那是“不美”或“不值得追求”的视角。所以在成长时期，她没有经历过我那样的感觉——觉得自己不如其他孩子，觉得黑人是否有什么问题，或者觉得自己格格不入。她没有那种经历。
Like all of us, Nikole's own experience raising a child is always running parallel to the memory of her own childhood. Parenting is an ongoing act of correction. Nikole grew up being bussed from her Black neighborhood to a mostly white, wealthier school. She was part of a desegregation plan. She's talked about the social isolation of being one of the only Black kids in school on our show before, the psychological toll of that.
和我们所有人一样，妮可养育孩子的经历总是与她自己的童年记忆并行。育儿是一个持续的纠错过程。妮可成长过程中是从黑人社区被校车送到白人占多数的富裕学校的。她是种族融合计划的一部分。她曾在节目中谈到作为学校里仅有的几名黑人孩子之一的社会孤立感，以及那种心理创伤。
And she didn't want that for Najya. And Najya was a different kid, growing up differently than Nikole did. Her parents had money and college degrees. Nikole wanted Najya to be in the mix with other kids, to see what she had that others didn't, and to feel comfortable with everyone.
她不想让纳贾重蹈覆辙。纳贾是个不同的孩子，成长环境也不一样。她的父母有钱也有大学学位。妮可希望纳贾融入其他孩子，了解自己拥有什么而别人没有，并对所有人感到自在。
I don't want my child to feel separate from other kids. I don't want her to feel that she's better than other kids. And she started to recognize the advantages that she had.
我不希望我的孩子觉得她和别人有隔阂。我不希望她觉得自己比别人优越。她开始意识到自己拥有的优势。
I remember she came home. There was a classmate whose older brother had been killed. And Najya was like, he doesn't have a coat. Can we get a coat for him? She had empathy and humanity.
我记得她回家时说，班上有个同学的哥哥被杀了。纳贾说：他没有外套，我们可以给他买一件吗？她有同理心，有人性。
And so I felt like that's why we're here. I believe in a common good. I believe that we have to be in it together.
我觉得这就是我们为什么在那里的原因。我相信共同利益，我相信我们必须同舟共济。
Nikole was prepared for some things in the school to be hard. And she and her husband Faraji were in the school often. Faraji volunteered regularly-- organizing parents, talking to teachers, addressing issues. He became co-president of the school's PTA. And still there was stuff they didn't know till they heard it from Najya, starting around first grade.
妮可准备好了迎接学校里的一些困难。她和丈夫法拉吉经常在校。法拉吉经常做志愿者——组织家长、与老师交谈、解决问题。他甚至成了家长教师协会的联合主席。但依然有些事是直到纳贾一年级时，他们才从孩子口中得知。
She would come home a lot and say things like, it's hard to concentrate. It's hard to focus, that there was a lot of disruption in the classroom, things that we know often happen in high-poverty schools.
她经常回家说：很难集中精力，很难专注于学习，课堂上有很多干扰。我们知道这在贫困学校里常发生。
And they were having an experience parents in high-poverty schools sometimes have. They were having trouble getting the school to respond, even though they were so involved. In fourth grade at a parent-teacher conference, Nikole and Faraji learned Najya was not on grade level, which was not something they'd heard before. So they immediately emailed her teachers and principals saying, we want to see her schoolwork. Please send home all her graded tests and assignments so we can look through them and see what's going on.
他们的经历也是贫困学校家长常有的——尽管他们参与度很高，却很难让学校做出回应。四年级时，在家长会后，妮可和法拉吉得知纳贾的学业水平没达标，这是他们此前从未听过的。于是他们立刻给老师和校长发邮件，说：我们需要看她的作业，请把她所有的评分试卷和作业发回来，我们要检查一下到底怎么回事。
They wouldn't send the schoolwork home. I asked them, and they wouldn't do it. I have to go to the principal. The principal instructs them to send the homework home. And they say, that's extra work for us.
他们不肯把作业发回来。我问他们，他们不照做。我只好去找校长。校长指示他们把作业带回家。他们却说：那对我们来说是额外工作。
So I'm having to take off from work. I'm coming up to the school all the time. I'm like, I need to see her work every week. This is crazy.
所以我不得不请假，经常去学校。我说：我每周都需要看她的作业。这太荒唐了。
And finally, the principal is able to get the teachers to send-- they send all this work home that Najya had been doing. And I start going through the math, and all the problems are wrong.
最终校长迫使老师们把作业带回家，当他们把纳贾做的所有作业发回来时，我开始检查数学部分，所有的题全错了。
Oh, no.
噢，不。
Like literally, almost all the problems are wrong.
真的，几乎所有的题都错了。
Like the answers are wrong?
意思是答案全错吗？
The answers. He's just putting a check mark. He's not checking her math. He's not correcting her. He's not teaching her. Every single one is wrong.
答案。他只是打了勾。他根本没检查她的数学，没有纠正她，没有教她。每一道题都错了。
Yeah, devastating parent moment. I'm like, what am I doing? What am I doing to my child? Like, I-- I felt like I was failing my child, like my decision was failing my child. God, I was so worried that I had done wrong by my child in a way that was irreparable.
那真是作为家长的毁灭性时刻。我在想：我在做什么？我对自己的孩子做了什么？我感觉自己辜负了孩子，我的决定在伤害我的孩子。天哪，我非常担心我以一种不可逆转的方式亏待了孩子。
I remember sitting at the table that night. And I was-- I mean, I'm not naive, but I was in shock. That was the one part of just what she wasn't learning. But there was the other part of this little girl who has all this confidence. She thinks she is amazing at math. She is smart, but she thinks she's academically doing well, and she's not.
我记得那天晚上坐在桌边，我并不天真，但我当时处于震惊中。这不仅是她没学到东西的部分，还有这个小女孩原本充满自信——她认为自己数学很棒，她很聪明，她认为自己在学术上表现良好，但实际上并非如此。
Nikole sat at the table, waiting for Faraji to get home.
妮可坐在桌边等待法拉吉回家。
And Faraji and I-- I remember as soon as he got home, I think he was maybe at a school board meeting or something like that. And I'm like, look at this. And it's like, well, what do we do? Do we leave? Do we take her out of this? [SIGHS]
法拉吉一到家——我记得他当时可能在参加学校董事会会议或其他活动——我就说：看这个。我们要怎么办？我们离开吗？我们带她走吗？（叹气）
And so we struggled with what to do. I mean, we felt stuck because those other kids did not deserve not to be taught either and the understanding that the consequences for them were going to be so much greater than for my child. These were already kids living in public housing, living in poverty, no power in our society.
我们纠结于该怎么做。我们感到被困住了，因为其他孩子也不该得不到教育，而且那种理解是：对他们来说，后果比对我孩子来说严重得多。这些孩子已经生活在公共住房里，在贫困中，在我们的社会里没有权力。
Faraji and I, we would have these discussions. And we would be like, who are we if the moment it gets really rough, we give up? Then what did we do it for in the first place? And in the end, we just felt we couldn't abandon the rest of those kids.
法拉吉和我讨论时常说：如果我们一旦遇到困难就放弃，那我们当初做这一切是为了什么？最后，我们觉得不能抛弃其他孩子。
They made a new plan. They would stay in the school, they would get Najya support, and they were going to get the school support. Nikole asked a friend, a former math teacher, to tutor Najya at home.
他们制定了新计划。他们会留在学校，为纳贾寻找支持，同时也要为学校争取支持。妮可找了一位朋友，一位前数学老师，在家给纳贾辅导。
And Nikole and Faraji threw themselves into getting help for the rest of her class. They demanded the principal provide remediation for the entire math class. They had numerous meetings with the district superintendent. He agreed to send an extra teacher into the classroom.
妮可和法拉吉投入了大量精力为纳贾班上的其他孩子寻求帮助。他们要求校长为整个数学班提供补习。他们与学区主管举行了多次会议，主管同意派一名额外教师进入教室。
Their teacher friend recruited other educators to come by the school and offer after-school tutoring. This was a sprawling, all-consuming project that took so much more time than simply addressing the problem for their own kid. But they'd say to each other, this is why we're here in the school, not just for their own child's success. Success for them was both and, Najya doing well and all the kids doing well.
他们的教师朋友招募了其他教育工作者到校提供课后辅导。这是一个庞大、耗费心力的工程，比仅仅解决自己孩子的问题要费时得多。但他们互相说：这就是我们留在这里的原因，不仅仅是为了自己孩子的成功。对他们来说，成功是“两者兼顾”——纳贾学得好，所有孩子也都学得好。
It's like we recommitted. We have to be here. We have to now make sure all these kids in this classroom's work is getting graded, that these teachers are actually teaching all these kids, not just our child. And that's what we did, but it tested us for sure.
就像我们重新做出了承诺。我们必须留在这里。现在必须确保班上所有孩子的作业都能得到评分，确保老师确实是在教所有孩子，而不仅仅是我们的孩子。这就是我们所做的，但确实考验了我们。
You said-- it actually might have been from your article, that it can feel unnatural. It can feel almost unnatural to put your child in a school that you think isn't the best, most perfect school. Did it feel unnatural to you?
你曾说——可能在你的文章里提到过，把孩子送去你认为不是最好、最完美的学校，感觉有时不那么自然。那对你来说感觉不自然吗？
Unnatural? Yes. Yeah.
不自然吗？是的。
Say more about that.
说说看。
I mean, every other decision that I'm making about my child is to try to give my child the best life possible-- trying to put her in the best situation, to give her the best examples, to protect her, make life easy for her. So no, it didn't feel natural. But a lot of things that are the right thing to do don't feel natural.
我为孩子做的每一个决定都是为了给她尽可能最好的生活——努力让她处于最好的境地，给她最好的榜样，保护她，让生活对她容易些。所以，不，这感觉不自然。但许多正确的事情往往感觉不自然。
So that was the balance of things at the end of elementary school, a shaky seesaw. They'd fought for better like they knew they'd have to. They got help for Najya like they thought they might have to. And they stayed committed.
这就是小学结束时的平衡，一个不稳定的跷跷板。他们像预料的那样为了好结果而战斗。他们像预期那样为纳贾寻求了帮助，并始终保持承诺。
For middle school, Nikole and Faraji chose a school in the neighborhood. It was mostly Black and low income. Test scores were not great. A public school plenty of parents would dismiss, but Nikole visited and liked it. Her district superintendent had recommended it as a school with a deeply committed principal who was on the ball, responsive to parents and students.
对于初中，妮可和法拉吉选择了社区里的一所学校。那里主要是黑人和低收入家庭。考试成绩并不理想。许多家长会避开这种公立学校，但妮可实地走访后很喜欢。学区主管推荐了这所学校，因为有一位深具责任感的校长，他关注学生，对家长和学生的需求反应迅速。
And important to Nikole, this school had never screened students like some of the more sought-after middle schools. It didn't select kids based on their grades or attendance records, or anything like that. It was open to everyone.
对妮可来说重要的是，这所学校从未像其他热门初中那样筛选学生。它不根据成绩、考勤记录或其他条件录取，它是对所有人开放的。
Najya made friends, joined the Food and Justice Club, did a lot of art. Outside school, she ran track. And then one day in seventh grade, Nikole and Najya were in the car. Najya was 12 years old. Nikole picked her up from school. And Najya said she and her friends had been researching schools online and looked up their own school.
纳贾交了朋友，加入了食品与正义俱乐部，画了很多画。校外她参加田径运动。七年级的一天，妮可和12岁的纳贾在车里。妮可接她放学，纳贾说她和朋友们在网上搜索学校，查到了她们自己的学校。
She was like, did you know my school had test scores like this when you decided to send me here? I paused, hand on the wheel driving. I'm looking straight ahead. And I'm sitting there like, OK, what am I going to say out of my mouth that's going to make sense to her?
她说：你决定送我到这里的时候，你知道我的学校考试成绩是这样的吗？我愣住了，手扶着方向盘，直视前方。我在想：我开口该说什么才能让她理解？
And it's like, I knew this day would come. I wouldn't say I talked a script over in my head of what I would say, but I knew it would come. And yet it's like the words that I'm formulating in my head to explain why I chose this really sounded really hollow.
我知道这一天会来。我没在脑子里打过草稿，但我知道会来。然而，我脑子里构建的解释为什么我做出这个选择的话语，听起来确实很空洞。
Like what? What were you--
像什么？你当时……
Well, you know. I'm like, yes, I knew that this school had these test scores, but test scores are not the most important thing about a school. And it was really important to me, my own values. I felt it was really important that you be in a school with most of the people in our neighborhood.
好吧，你知道的。我回答：是的，我知道这所学校考试成绩不好，但考试成绩并不是学校最重要的事。对我个人价值观而言，这非常重要。我觉得你能够和我们社区的大多数人待在一起非常重要。
And she's sitting there. And I see out of the corner of my eye this look like, that sounds crazy. Like, what? You mean you had all these resources. You could have sent me anywhere. You could have sent me to the best schools. And you're saying you just chose not to?
她坐在那里。我从余光里看到她的表情，那意思仿佛在说：这听起来太疯狂了。你是什么意思？你拥有所有这些资源，你本可以送我去任何地方。你可以送我去最好的学校。而你说你选择不去？
So your child is asking you a question that you have-- you've spoken about this on hundreds of stages. You've written hundreds of pages about it. You know what to say. Why do you not know what to say?
所以你的孩子问了你一个问题，这个问题你已经在数百个舞台上讲过，写了数百页的文字。你知道该说什么。为什么你反而不知道该说什么了？
I do know what to say. And I say it. But what I'm saying is, as I'm saying it, I know it sounds hollow coming out of my mouth, but I really believe that. I mean, I come from a people where I know my life, literally, in a literal way, is only possible because people were willing to sacrifice for a larger good.
我知道该说什么。我确实说了。但我想说的是，当我讲出来时，我知道这听起来很空洞，但我确实坚信那一点。我来自这样一个群体：我知道我的生活，字面意义上，之所以可能，是因为有人愿意为更大的利益做出牺牲。
I mean sacrifice like put your child through a white mob sacrifice. Sacrifice like get assassinated on your front lawn sacrifice. Sacrifice like get thrown off of the land that you worked. If everyone says, well, I would love to do that-- I believe in the concept of equality, but I can't make a personal sacrifice-- we don't get there. I don't live my life.
我的意思的牺牲是：牺牲到把孩子送进暴徒面前；牺牲到在自家前草坪被暗杀；牺牲到被赶出你耕耘的土地。如果每个人都说：“我很乐意那么做……我相信平等的概念，但我无法做出个人牺牲”——我们就永远无法实现目标。我就不会有今天的生活。
So I know what I'm saying to her is right, but I also know that she is a 12-year-old child who looks at you not to give her moral clarity, but to give her a life of opportunity. So now I'm just repeating what I've said and hoping that she'll move on. But she is not. She's angry.
所以我知道我对她说的是对的，但我也知道她是一个12岁的孩子，她看着你不是为了寻求道德启发，而是为了获得充满机会的生活。所以我只是在重复我说过的话，希望她能放下。但她没有。她很生气。
It hasn't been-- she's like, it's not a good school, and I could have been at a good school. And so it's like just round and around. And now I'm like, oh my god. She's really not going to let this go.
她不买账。她说：这不是所好学校，我本来可以去更好的学校。就这样没完没了。我现在心想：天哪，她真的不会让这件事过去。
Did you think, she's going to ask me about this sometime. I'm going to explain to her. Did you think about just giving her your article?
你有没有想过，“她迟早会问我这个问题的。我要向她解释。”你有没有想过直接把文章给她看？
No. My child's not reading 10,000 words that I write.
没有。我的孩子才不会读我写的那些一万字文章。
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
She's not. She's not.
她不会的。
She's on the cover, though. It's her picture.
封面是她啊。那是她的照片。
She's on the cover. No. Uh-uh, no.
封面是她。不，不，不。
Really? Has she never read it? Do you think she's never read it?
真的吗？她从没读过？你觉得她从没读过吗？
I don't think so.
我不认为她读过。
Nuh-uh. I don't believe that. Really?
不，我不相信。真的？
I promise. When you ask her, the answer is going to be no.
我保证。当你问她时，答案会是“没有”。
I am going to ask her. That's coming up, the answer to that question and so many others. I talked to Najya, and then she and her mom talk. No one is a prophet in her own home. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
我会问她的。答案即将揭晓，包括那个问题和其他许多问题。我采访了纳贾，然后她和她妈妈进行了对话。在这个世上，没人能在自己家中成为先知。稍后继续收听，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt sitting in for Ira Glass. Today's show, "An Argument." Act Two-- Najya.
这是《美国生活》。我是查娜·乔菲-沃尔特，代替艾拉·格拉斯主持。今天的节目是“一个论点”。第二幕——纳贾。
Because of who Nikole is and what we've talked about over years, I've thought about Najya more than I've thought about most other children who are not my own. From when she was little, I'd heard what Nikole wanted for her young daughter. I'd read her old article where she'd written about what she hoped for. And I've wondered, what's this all going to be like for Najya? Somehow back then, I never really imagined there would be a day when I might get to just ask her.
因为妮可是谁，以及我们多年来的交谈，我想到纳贾的次数比其他非亲生孩子要多。从她小时候起，我就听过妮可对女儿的期许。我读过她那篇关于选择学校希望的文章。我一直好奇：这对纳贾来说会是什么感觉？当年，我从未想象过会有那么一天，能直接问她。
OK, your mom told me she didn't know if you had read the article about choosing your elementary school. Have you read that article?
好的，你妈妈告诉我，她不知道你有没有读过那篇关于选择你小学学校的文章。你读过吗？
[LAUGHS] No.
（笑）没读过。
You've never read that article?
你从没读过那篇文章？
Well, no, I have not. I've never read it. I've never found myself to read it. Maybe I should because of my mom.
嗯，没读过。我从未主动去读。也许因为是我妈妈写的，我应该读读。
Well, also because it's about you.
嗯，而且它是关于你的。
Well, yeah, but I never read it.
是的，但我确实没读过。
Najya has been listening to her mom give talks her whole life. She says she knows what the article was about, her school. She went to her school. She lived it. She didn't have to read about it. What was the school her mom chose, wrote 10,000 words about choosing, actually like for Najya?
纳贾一辈子都在听她妈妈演讲。她说她知道文章关于什么，关于她的学校。她上了那所学校，她亲身经历过。她不需要看文章。她妈妈选择的那所学校，那篇写了一万字的文章，对纳贾来说究竟是什么样的？
It was just regular. It was fine.
很普通，还可以。
It was just school?
就只是学校而已？
Yeah, I don't really remember a lot from elementary. I was really into art. I liked to draw a lot. I was-- yeah, I was loud. I still am chatty.
是的，我不记得小学发生过什么大事。我那时迷上画画，我喜欢画画。我很吵，我现在依然很爱聊天。
Did you ever wonder why you were in that elementary school?
你有想过为什么你要在那所小学吗？
No. It was just a school that she picked for me. I didn't really care about it. I wasn't ever thinking about stuff like that.
没有。那只是她为我选的学校。我并不关心。我从未考虑过那种事。
She was lonely sometimes when girls were mean, regular kid stuff. Najya remembers fourth grade, they didn't do much in class and that her mom had issues with her teachers. She thought it was weird that her third grade teacher was absent a lot, but fifth grade was fun. It was all fine.
当女孩们刻薄时，她有时会感到孤独，都是些普通孩子的烦恼。纳贾记得四年级时，课堂上没学到什么东西，而且妈妈和老师有过冲突。她觉得三年级老师经常缺席很奇怪，但五年级很有趣。一切都还好。
What Najya wanted to talk about more was middle school, sixth grade. That's when things got hard for her. She says in middle school, other kids made it hard to learn. There were fights.
纳贾更想谈论的是初中，六年级。那时情况变难了。她说在初中，其他孩子让学习变得困难，经常打架。
Problems all the time. We wouldn't even be able to play in gym because the kids wouldn't stop acting out. It would be all the time. They would be throwing fart bombs and stuff. There was no punishment. It wasn't stopped.
总是有麻烦。我们在体育课上甚至没法玩，因为孩子们总在捣乱。一直如此。他们会扔臭屁弹之类的东西。没有任何惩罚。没人阻止。
So because of that, it's just not fun. You can't do anything, and they're ruining your chances to do things just because they can't act right. It was really bad.
正因为如此，一点也不好玩。你什么都做不了，他们就因为自己无法规矩行为，毁掉了我们做事的机会。真的很糟糕。
I think I would come home complaining to my mom all the time like, bro, these kids are always fighting, and they're always disrupting class. I'm not trying to be in this type of environment. And I wasn't enjoying it.
我想我当时经常回家跟我妈抱怨，像说：“哥们，这些孩子总在打架，总在干扰课堂。”我不想在这种环境下。我不享受它。
I remember we got our report cards back. I think there was seven kids in that class who were on honor roll, and the rest were like, they didn't. The school was so easy, and how did you not get-- I don't know.
我记得拿到成绩单时，班上只有七个孩子上了荣誉榜，剩下的都没有。学校太简单了，为什么他们拿不到……我不知道。
Wait, you're like, how did people not get honor roll? Is that what you mean?
等等，你的意思是“为什么他们拿不到荣誉榜”？你是这个意思吗？
Right. Because it was like-- it was just a really easy school.
是的。因为那学校真的太简单了。
Did you have homework?
你有作业吗？
No.
没有。
No homework?
没有作业？
No, none, zero.
没有，零。
How did you feel about that?
你对此感觉如何？
I thought it was bad. I think I complained about it to my friends, like, we don't get anything. We're not getting any work. We're not getting any work at home.
我觉得很糟糕。我想我曾跟朋友抱怨过，像说：“我们什么也得不到。我们没有作业，我们在家也没有任何练习。”
You wanted homework?
你想要作业？
We did. We did. We honestly did want to get more things because we knew that we weren't learning enough. We didn't know anything.
我们想要。我们确实想要更多任务，因为我们知道自己学得不够。我们什么也不懂。
Najya was building her own assessment of her school, drawing on what she was seeing and what she wanted for herself. For her, a good school had homework. A good school was an organized school. Najya used that word a lot when we talked. Her school was not organized.
纳贾正在建立自己对学校的评价，基于她所看到的和她对自己想要的理解。对她来说，好的学校有作业。好的学校是有组织的。纳贾交谈时经常用到“有组织”这个词。她的学校没有组织。
And then in seventh grade, Najya's teachers and friends started talking about the next step, high school. New York City has hundreds of high schools. The top schools, there are things you have to do. You have to apply, get good grades. You have to take a test or audition. It's a whole process. You need to do research, go on tours. You have to engage.
七年级时，纳贾的老师和朋友们开始讨论下一步——高中。纽约市有数百所高中。顶级学校需要你去做很多事：申请、取得好成绩、参加测试或面试。这是一个完整的流程。你需要做调研、参观。你必须投入。
If you're an ambitious seventh grader or even just a kid who cares about status as nearly every seventh grader does, this is when you start to become aware, if you're not already, that there are, quote, "good schools" and "bad schools," and you fit somewhere in that system. And if you didn't know about it till now, you are probably already behind. Najya and her friends started researching the top high schools. It was in doing that research that they looked up their own school.
如果你是一个雄心勃勃的七年级学生，或者像几乎所有七年级学生一样在意身份地位，你就会开始意识到有“好学校”和“烂学校”，而你在这个系统中处于某个位置。如果你到现在还不知道，那你可能已经落后了。纳贾和朋友们开始研究顶级高中。就是在做调研时，她们查到了自己的学校。
And we were just shocked. Test scores were really low. Everything about the school was really low.
我们感到震惊。考试成绩非常低。学校的所有指标都很低。
What did you think when you saw that?
当你看到那个时是怎么想的？
I was like, wow. That's why we're not getting anything. We have nothing. You see all the reviews. You see the parent reviews. You see student reviews. You see everything.
我心想：哇。这就是为什么我们什么都没学到。我们什么都没有。你看到了所有的评价。家长评论，学生评价。你看到了所有东西。
And test scores.
还有考试成绩。
Mm-hmm. I think we looked at those scores all the time.
嗯。我想我们一直在看那些成绩。
You did?
你们真的看了？
Yeah, I think we looked at them all the time.
对，我想我们一直在看。
Like, you kept returning?
就是说，你们不断地回去查？
Mm-hmm. We kept looking at other sites, like how the school was. And it was not great.
嗯。我们不断查看其他网站，了解学校的情况。结果并不好。
She remembers bringing this information to her mom, and she remembers her mom trying to explain her thinking, but Najya doesn't remember exactly what her mom said because she says it made no sense.
她记得把这些信息带给她妈妈，也记得妈妈试着解释她的想法，但纳贾不记得妈妈具体说了什么，因为她说那根本说不通。
I didn't ever agree with her response. All I know is that I wasn't having it. I was just like, why? Why am I here?
我从没同意过她的回应。我只知道我受够了。我只是想问：为什么？为什么我在这里？
Najya was mad, and she wanted an answer.
纳贾很生气，她想要一个答案。
Act Three-- Najya's Choice. Nikole tried to answer Najya's questions over and over, but Nikole understood things about Najya's school and the school system in general that Najya, as an 11 and 12-year-old, did not. Nikole knew that because her middle school didn't screen students, because it didn't select some students and turn others away, what that meant is the school had a high concentration of kids who showed up on day one to middle school already behind. Most kids had gone to elementary schools that were struggling, many had diagnosed learning disabilities, and almost all of them experienced poverty outside of school.
第三幕——纳贾的选择。妮可一遍又一遍地试图回答纳贾的问题，但妮可理解的关于纳贾的学校和整个学校系统的事情，纳贾作为一个11、12岁的孩子并不理解。妮可知道，因为纳贾的初中不筛选学生，不对学生拒之门外，这意味着学校里聚集了大量在初中第一天就落后的孩子。大多数孩子上的是挣扎中的小学，许多人被诊断有学习障碍，而且几乎所有人在校外都经历着贫困。
From Nikole's perspective, Najya's middle school was doing a pretty good job of trying to serve all its students. Nikole had been inside lots of schools as a reporter. And to her, Najya's school wasn't one that was neglecting students or lacking organization. It seemed organized and deeply caring, and unlike Najya's elementary school, responsive.
在妮可看来，纳贾的初中在试图服务好所有学生方面做得不错。作为记者，妮可进过很多学校。对她而言，纳贾的学校并不属于那种忽视学生或缺乏组织的学校。它看起来很有秩序，深切关怀学生，而且不像小学那样对家长诉求充耳不闻。
When Nikole brought Najya's complaints to teachers and administrators, they got back to her right away. They tried in earnest to address things. But none of that was changing how Najya felt. She kept returning to their argument about why she was at this school, why, at sometimes random moments.
当妮可把纳贾的抱怨带给老师和行政人员时，他们立刻给予了回应。他们真诚地试图解决问题。但这些并没改变纳贾的感受。她不断回到她们的争论点：为什么她在这所学校？为什么有时是在一些随机的时刻。
She would-- we'd be in the kitchen preparing food, and she'd be like, I still don't understand why you did that. And I'm like, oh my god. [LAUGHS] I'm like, she's not going to let-- she's not letting it go. And you know what she said was like, you weren't in the classroom.
她会……我们正在厨房准备食物，她会说：我还是不明白你为什么要那样做。我心想：天啊。（笑）我心想：她不会放过这件事的。你知道她说的是：你又不在教室里。
It's not your experience.
这不是你的经历。
It's not your education. It's not your experience. And I deeply heard that. And she's not an eight-year-old child. She is a young woman who's done her research.
这不是你的教育，不是你的经历。我深深听进去了。她不是八岁的孩子。她是位年轻女性，她做过研究。
And I'm like, I just don't want-- I don't want this to haunt me for the rest of our relationship. That's why what I ultimately decided-- this is like-- I don't know-- fifth, sixth conversation slash argument where I said, you know, you are absolutely justified in feeling how you feel. You certainly, if I had made different choices, would have had very different educational experience. And because of that, I'm going to now let you make the choice for your educational experience going forward. For high school, I would let her choose.
我心想：我不希望这件事成为我们未来关系的阴影。这就是为什么我最终决定——这是……不知道……第五或第六次谈话，我说：你知道，你的感受是完全合理的。如果我做了不同的选择，你肯定会有非常不同的教育经历。正因为如此，从现在起，我让你自己做出教育选择。高中，我会让你自己选。
Wow.
哇。
She would decide what school she wanted to visit, and she would decide what school she wanted to apply for.
她决定参观哪所学校，决定申请哪所学校。
This is at 12? She's 12 at the time? This is a 12-year-old?
这是12岁时？她当时12岁？这是一个12岁的孩子？
Yeah.
是的。
And what was her reaction?
她的反应是什么？
If anybody has ever parented a 12-year-old girl, then you know her reaction was like, yeah, but you still shouldn't have did that.
如果你做过12岁女孩的家长，你就知道她的反应是：是的，但你当初还是不该那样做。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
I still want to talk about what you did. You're trying to move on, but I'm not over that. So that was her response. But then she was like, really? You're really going to let me? And I was like, absolutely. OK. Great.
我还是想讨论你做的事情。你想翻篇，但我还没过去。所以这就是她的反应。但后来她说：真的吗？你真的让我自己选？我说：当然。好吧，太好了。
I'm going to a school that I want for myself. I'm going to a school that's going to be hard to get into, that's really good, that has high scores. That's what I wanted to do. I wanted better education, just learning more or homework, having more curriculars or just more subjects. I didn't want to be in a majority Black school. I thought I wanted more of a diverse community.
我要去一所我自己想要的学校。我要去一所很难进去、真的很棒、分数很高的学校。这就是我想做的。我想要更好的教育，学更多东西，有作业，有更多课外活动或科目。我不想待在黑人占多数的学校。我以为我想要一个更多元化的社区。
Why?
为什么？
I felt like if I was in a diverse community, a more diverse or less Black-- or not less Black, but more diverse community, I would get better education because that's what it seemed like.
我觉得如果我在一个多元社区，一个更多元或不是那么黑人……不是说“不是黑人”，而是更多元的社区，我会得到更好的教育，因为看起来就是这样。
Where did you get that idea from? Why did it seem that way to you?
这个想法从哪来的？为什么看起来会是那样？
Because you see it in your school. You see all these schools' procedures. They're mainly Asian or mainly white. And it's like, if I've been in these schools where it's majority Black, it's like I'm not getting anything from it at all. If you look at the top schools, they're majority white. And it's like, if you want to go to a good school, you're going to have to go to a majority white school.
因为你在学校里看到了。你看到了所有学校的流程。它们大多是亚洲人或白人为主。看起来就是，如果你在黑人为主的学校，你就什么也学不到。如果你看看顶级学校，它们是白人为主。所以，如果你想去一所好学校，你必须去白人为主的学校。
She comes back with her list of schools, and I internally cringed.
她拿回她的学校列表时，我内心感到一阵退缩。
Why?
为什么？
Well, what my daughter did was looked up the top-achieving schools in the city. She found out the best, in terms of test score, schools in the city. And that was her list.
因为我女儿调研的是全城成绩顶尖的学校。她找出了考试成绩最好的学校。那份名单就是她选的。
The exact opposite of your approach.
和你方法完全相反。
Yeah. [LAUGHS]
是的。（笑）
What'd you do with your face?
你当时脸上什么表情？
No, I don't think I actually-- it's impossible for me to have a neutral face, but I try. I work very hard. I'm like, I cannot believe this. My child came up with the exact opposite of my life's work. And every school on there is a school that screens and has hardly no Black kids.
不，我不认为我真的……我不露声色是不可能的，但我尝试了。我非常努力。我心想：我无法相信。我的孩子做出的决定和我毕生的事业完全相反。名单上的每一所学校都是筛选学生、几乎没有黑人孩子的学校。
Najya organized everything for high school. She researched the schools, found out when they had tours, how you get into them. The only time Nikole intervened was to insist that Najya at least tour a selective, high-achieving, majority Black high school. Otherwise, Nikole kept her word and let Najya take the reins. Najya began imagining more and more what she wanted from school, where she was heading in high school and beyond high school. Nikole teaches at Howard University, an HBCU, the mecca of Black education and excellence.
纳贾自己安排了高中申请的一切。她调研学校，查参观时间，了解入学方式。妮可唯一干预的一次是坚持让纳贾至少参观一所重点招收、学术表现优秀的黑人为主的高中。除此之外，妮可守信，放手让纳贾做主。纳贾开始更多地构思她想要的学校，她高中乃至高中以后的去向。妮可在霍华德大学任教，那是一所历史悠久的黑人大学（HBCU），黑人教育与卓越的麦加。
Yeah, I mean, look, I've been ingraining Howard into her since she was three years old. And then one day she comes back from middle school, and she says she wants to go to Harvard. And I was like, we have never mentioned the word "Harvard" in our household. What the hell is happening?
是的，我是说，你看，从她三岁起我就在给她灌输霍华德大学。然后有一天她从初中回来，说她想去哈佛。我说：我们家从来没提过“哈佛”这个词。到底发生了什么？
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
I'm like, what? But like she did for high schools, she looked up the top-ranked school and decided that's where she wanted to go.
我心想：什么？她就像选高中一样，查了排名第一的学校，决定那就是她想去的地方。
You're literally like, where did this girl learn the word "Harvard?"
你真是……这个女孩是从哪学的“哈佛”这个词？
Harvard. Yes. I'm telling you, we don't even discuss PWIs as an option in our household.
哈佛。没错。我告诉你，我们家甚至不把PWI（以白人为主的机构）作为选项讨论。
Predominantly white institution.
以白人为主的机构。
Yeah, predominantly white--
是的，白人为主……
Yeah.
是的。
And especially not Harvard. Like, Harvard? Child. Because I'm like, did I mishear you? Did you accidentally say Howard? No.
尤其不是哈佛。像哈佛？孩子，我怀疑我是不是听错了？你是不是不小心说了霍华德？不是。
I love that your child's rebellion is to tell her mother that she wants to go to Harvard University.
我很喜欢你孩子反叛的方式居然是告诉她妈妈想去哈佛大学。
Exactly, and I'm disappointed. I'm like, what is wrong with you?
正是，而我感到失望。我心想：你到底怎么了？
You have to admire that the child is like, whatever is the best, that's what I want.
你不得不钦佩这孩子，她想的完全是“不管什么最好，我就要那个”。
Yeah.
是的。
I both admired it and was appalled at the same time. Like, where are you getting these ideas? Who is putting these crazy ideas in your head?
我既钦佩又同时感到震惊。像：这些想法是从哪来的？谁把这些疯狂的想法塞进你脑子的？
Najya submitted her high school application, ranking a dozen high-achieving schools, and she got into her top choice-- a majority white and Asian school in a wealthy neighborhood almost an hour commute by subway from her home. She started freshman year.
纳贾提交了高中申请，排了十几所高学术水平的学校，并被第一志愿录取了——那是一所位于富裕社区、白人和亚裔为主的学校，从家坐地铁通勤要近一个小时。她开始了高一生活。
Within two weeks, she was ready to transfer. She wanted to transfer out of the school.
两周内，她就准备转学了。她想转出那所学校。
Wow.
哇。
And I told her no. I was like, look, we went through a whole process. You're going to stay here, and we're going to figure it out. This is life. This is real life.
我告诉她不行。我说：你看，我们经历了一整个过程。你要留在那里，我们会想办法。这就是生活。这就是现实生活。
The girls were different. I noticed that there were kids that were comfortable saying the N-word. I also experienced that.
那些女孩很不一样。我注意到有些孩子对“黑鬼”这个词很习以为常。我也经历过。
There were white kids that were saying the N-word.
有白人孩子说那个词？
Yeah. That's everywhere, but it was like I never really experienced that in person. It was like kids that also came from very good homes, kids that also came from very rich households.
是的。那到处都有，但我以前从没当面经历过。就像那些孩子也来自很好的家庭，也来自非常富有的家庭。
And did that affect you or--
那影响到你了吗？
I thought they were too bougie and had high egos, but unaware, don't know about anything social-wise, nothing about Black people or nothing about this, just unaware about a lot of things and a lot of things in history, just really privileged and spoiled.
我觉得她们太矫情了，自尊心很强，但一无所知，在社交上什么都不懂，对黑人或者其他任何东西一无所知，对历史也知之甚少，只是非常受宠、娇惯。
And ignorant.
而且无知。
Very ignorant.
非常无知。
Mm-hmm. Got it. OK.
嗯，明白了。好吧。
Yeah.
是的。
How were the academics? That was the thing you had really wanted.
学业方面呢？那是你真正想要的。
When I got into that school and they were talking about all these things, I'm like, what are we talking about? I never learned this. So it was bumpy. It was hard. It was really stressful.
我进入那所学校时，她们谈论的一切让我心想：我们在讨论什么？我从来没学过这些。所以，很颠簸。很难。真的很令人压力。
Yeah, that sounds stressful.
是的，听起来压力很大。
I've never got a C before. I never really got those grades in middle school. And when I saw that, now it was just like-- [GROANS] It sucked a lot.
我以前从没拿过C。我在初中时从没拿过那种成绩。看到那个时，真的……（呻吟）真的很糟。
She didn't feel like she fit in. She didn't feel like she had anything in common with most of the kids.
她觉得她不合群。她觉得和大多数孩子没有什么共同点。
Were you surprised that that was her experience the first few weeks?
你惊讶那是她最初几周的经历吗？
No, not at all. That experience I have had.
完全不惊讶。那种经历我也有过。
That was the experience you were trying to protect her from.
那是你试图保护她免受的经历。
Exactly.
正是。
One of them.
其中一种。
One of them, yeah. Probably the most devastating thing is you spend their whole lifetime trying to build up the sense of themselves just as a parent parenting a child, but also me trying to build my child's confidence as a Black girl and the inherent intellect and worth. And then it can be destroyed in two weeks in this school.
其中之一，是的。可能最毁灭性的事情是，你花了一辈子试图建立她们对自我的认知，既是一个家长的本能，也是我试图作为黑人女孩的母亲建立孩子的自信以及与生俱来的理智和价值。然后，它可能在这所学校里两周就被摧毁了。
Freshman year, it was the first time a teacher ever called about behavior for Najya. That had never happened. She had never had behavior problems. She was angry. She was really angry for much of that year.
高一，那是纳贾第一次因为行为问题被老师叫家长。这以前从未发生过。她以前从未有过行为问题。她很愤怒。那一年的大部分时间她都很愤怒。
Nikole and Faraji focused on getting Najya tutoring and support. And Najya settled in. She made new friends. She caught up academically. She stopped asking to transfer. She's doing well. This was the new status quo. And this is where they were when I started talking to Nikole and Najya, toward the end of Najya's sophomore year, the second year at the high school that she had chosen for herself.
妮可和法拉吉专注于为纳贾找补习和支持。纳贾安顿了下来。她交了新朋友。她补上了学业。她不再要求转学。她表现得很好。这就是新的现状。这就是当我们开始和妮可、纳贾交谈时她们的状态，接近纳贾高二结束时，也就是她自己选择的高中的第二年。
Nikole and Najya had come into the studio to talk, not knowing exactly what the other thought about this whole experience now. Some time had passed, and they'd stopped fighting about it. Nikole had not written her new article about all of this yet, and she had questions. She thought now that Najya was doing so well-- she'd been able to get into her top school and succeed there-- Nikole wanted to know if I asked Najya what she thought of her mom's choice, would she still say it was terrible?
妮可和纳贾来到演播室交谈，不知道对方现在对这段经历怎么看。一段时间过去了，她们停止了争吵。妮可还没写关于这一切的新文章，她有问题。她想现在纳贾表现得这么好——她能考进最好的学校并在那里成功——妮可想知道，如果我问纳贾怎么看她妈妈的选择，她还会说是可怕的吗？
Act Four-- Nikole and Najya. When they showed up together, I could tell just by watching the way they interact that Nikole and Najya enjoy spending time together. They're comfortable.
第四幕——妮可和纳贾。她们一起出现时，我一眼就能看出她们母女互动融洽。她们很自在。
Najya's 16 years old now. She tells me her top pick for college is Howard-- not Harvard, Howard. She likes it, she says, because it's in DC. It's got a nice campus. Plus, she says, I'd get to be with my mom. They both act like this is a completely regular thing for a 16-year-old to say and want, and that is how I know they're close and that a lot has changed.
纳贾现在16岁了。她告诉我她大学第一志愿是霍华德——不是哈佛，是霍华德。她说她喜欢它，因为它在华盛顿特区。校园很漂亮。而且，她说：我还能和我妈妈在一起。她们两个人的表现好像这是16岁孩子想说、想做的非常正常的事情，我由此知道她们很亲近，而且很多事情已经改变了。
I had talked to Nikole about all this twice on her own before she came in with Najya. And I talked to Najya alone for almost an hour and a half while her mom waited outside. I got Najya's thoughts on the experiences she'd had and the different schools. And it wasn't until the very end when I said, is there anything else you want to say, that Najya mentioned the argument with her mom. They hadn't had it for a long time, but Najya said she had brought it up again when she was feeling behind at the beginning of high school.
我在她们一起进来之前，曾独自与妮可谈过两次这一切。我独自采访了纳贾近一个半小时，她妈妈在外等候。我了解了纳贾对所经历的事情和不同学校的看法。直到最后我说“还有什么想说的吗”，纳贾才提到和她妈妈的争论。她们很久没吵架了，但纳贾说她在高一刚开始感觉落后时又提起过。
Like, Mom, if you didn't put me in these schools, I would have been OK.
像：“妈，如果你没把我送到这些学校，我本来会很好的。”
What'd she say?
她说什么了？
She said the same thing. She said-- I don't know what she said. I wouldn't know what she said.
她说了一样的话。她说……我不知道她说了什么。我不会知道她说了什么。
She said something.
她说了些什么的。
All I know is that I complained to her, so.
我只知道我向她抱怨了，所以。
So you know that she said the same thing that she said the last time you had the conversation, but you don't actually know what that thing was?
所以你知道她说了和你上次对话时一样的话，但你其实不知道那是什么？
Yeah, I don't know what it was.
是的，我不知道是什么。
Do you want to know?
你想知道吗？
Yes.
想。
I think we could probably get the answer from her because she's sitting right outside here. Nikole, you up for coming in?
我想我们可以从她那里得到答案，因为她就坐在外面。妮可，你愿意进来吗？
[DOOR OPENING]
（门打开声）
Hello, Nikole.
你好，妮可。
Hello.
你好。
Nikole sits next to Najya, and they talk. I'm going to bleep the name of Najya's high school when it comes up in this conversation. They're sitting side by side, and Nikole begins laying out her case. She's clear, vulnerable, tells Najya this was a hard choice, the hardest choice.
妮可坐在纳贾旁边，她们交谈起来。在这次对话中，我要把纳贾的高中名字消音。她们并排坐着，妮可开始陈述她的立场。她清晰、脆弱，告诉纳贾这是一个艰难的选择，最艰难的选择。
Najya still seems to be listening carefully. As Nikole says, public education is just so deeply unequal and always has been. Black kids in particular segregated and denied a fair and equal education.
纳贾似乎仍在仔细倾听。妮可说，公立教育极其不平等，而且一直如此。尤其是黑人孩子，被隔离在平等的教育之外。
What do we then do? Do we just say, well, there's nothing I can do? Or do you try in some way to make some intervention? It's like, why should my child be the one that's rescued? You should escape what we consign so many other kids just like you to. I just will never feel right right about that.
那我们该怎么办？我们就说“好吧，我无能为力”吗？还是你试图以某种方式进行干预？就像：为什么我的孩子应该是被拯救的那一个？你应该逃离我们把许多像你一样的其他孩子遗弃在里面的环境。关于这一点，我永远不会感觉是对的。
Why? It makes no sense. You're talking about, oh, I'm just going to give you the worst just because it's not fair that you-- I didn't ask to be born. All you're supposed to do is just put me in a good school. Like, oh, well, I didn't want to put you in a great school and have you have advantages over other kids.
为什么？这毫无意义。你说：哦，我只是想给你最差的，仅仅因为这对你不公平……我没要求出生。你所要做的只是把我送进好学校。就像：哦，好吧，我不想把你送进名校，让你比其他孩子有优势。
Isn't that what you want? Isn't that what you want me to have? Is that not a normal thing you want me to have? You don't want me to have this--
那不是你想要的吗？那不是你想要我拥有的吗？这不是你想要我拥有的正常东西吗？你不想让我拥有这种……
You do, though.
你有的，虽然。
OK, yeah, but--
好吧，是的，但……
But you do. You have advantages. You have so many advantages.
但你确实有。你有优势。你有这么多优势。
Right, OK, so-- but I'm not seeing them. I'm saying school-wise. I'm in school every day. I was in that building every single day. That doesn't make sense. I'm there more than home. Obviously, I get more in general, but school is the most important thing. That's the main thing.
对，好吧，但我没看到。我说的是学业方面。我每天都在学校。我每天都在那栋楼里。这没意义。我在那待的时间比在家多。显然，我总体上得到的更多，但学校是最重要的。那是主要的事情。
Why do you imagine you're able to do well in [BLEEP]?
你为什么想象自己在[消音]表现得好？
Because it's a better school.
因为它是所更好的学校。
But you, do you think it's possible your foundation wasn't as terrible as you think it is?
但你认为你的基础可能不像你想象的那么差吗？
No.
不。
So you think you came in like a blank slate at [BLEEP] and now have learned everything there?
所以你认为你是像一张白纸进入[消音]的，现在已经在那里学到了一切？
No, but--
不是，但……
You have been able to have the same academic success as your classmates.
你已经能够获得和同学们一样的学术成功了。
Yeah, to get through it because-- well, not even though. Last year, when I had my grade come out, I remember crying because everyone else's score was so good. And I was just like, how is this so easy for everyone else but me? So no, I don't think that I got through it. I think I just tried my hardest.
是的，坚持下来因为……好吧，也不算是坚持。去年我成绩出来时，我记得哭了，因为别人的分数都那么好。我当时心想：为什么这事对别人这么容易，对我却这么难？所以不，我不觉得我坚持下来了。我觉得我只是尽了最大努力。
Yeah. I mean, I think it's fair to say you did not receive the top quality middle school education.
是的。我的意思是，我认为公平地说，你没有接受过顶尖水平的初中教育。
Either in elementary with--
还有小学……
That's fair.
这是公平的。
--even basic fractions. I mean, I was never taught that. I had to relearn everything from my tutor.
……甚至基本的分数运算。我从来没学过。我不得不从我的辅导老师那里重新学一切。
That's fair.
这是公平的。
Everyone's not your kid.
每个人都不是你的孩子。
That's fair.
这是公平的。
You can't save everyone who doesn't want to be saved.
你无法拯救每一个不想被拯救的人。
Oh. That's what you think, though? You think other kids don't want better?
噢，你是这么想的吗？你觉得其他孩子不想变得更好？
I'm not saying that. I wanted better. All the kids in my school that wanted better wanted better. There's no benefit that came out of you putting me in those schools. There's no benefit at all. Could you tell me a benefit?
我不是那个意思。我想要更好。我学校里所有想变得更好的孩子都想变得更好。你把我送进那些学校没带来任何益处。根本没有益处。你能告诉我一个益处吗？
You want me to answer that? Benefit for the school?
你想让我回答吗？对学校的益处？
What benefit did you provide the school?
你为学校提供了什么益处？
I think that's a great question. I do think it was a benefit of us being in those schools. We brought resources. If you remember--
我认为这是个好问题。我确实认为我们在那些学校是有益处的。我们带来了资源。如果你还记得……
Nikole runs through a bunch of examples-- your dad organizing parents at the school, intervening when there were issues with teachers, making sure kids who couldn't afford field trips would still get those opportunities. The principal creating a recognition breakfast for kids who made the honor roll wouldn't have happened if you weren't in the school. Nikole goes big and specific. The benefits of kids having friends from different backgrounds our moral obligations to one another.
妮可列举了一堆例子——你爸爸组织家长，在老师出现问题时介入，确保那些买不起校外考察门票的孩子仍能得到那些机会。校长为上荣誉榜的孩子举办的表彰早餐，如果不是因为你在学校，那根本不会发生。妮可列举了宏观和具体的益处。孩子们能和不同背景的人交朋友，我们对他人的道德义务。
Najya is not waiting for her to be done. She's jumping in. Opportunities for all kids, like what? You made friends with different kinds of people. Who? Dad being involved had a big impact? How?
纳贾没等她说完就插话了：给所有孩子的机会，像什么？你交了不同类型的朋友。谁？爸爸参与有很大影响？怎么影响的？
We don't have to actually agree. It's OK for us to see this in a different way. But ultimately, you got into your first choice of high school.
我们不需要真正达成共识。我们可以以不同的方式看待这件事。但最终，你还是进了你的高中首选志愿。
But you could have had me way higher in education.
但你本可以让我接受更好的教育。
Do you feel like your life is being held back?
你觉得你的生活被拖后腿了吗？
I don't think that, but I don't want to be-- I don't want to-- I didn't want to feel like I didn't know anything because I was set back in other schools. I didn't want to feel like I was dumb. In ninth grade, I did feel like I was dumb. It did feel like I didn't know anything. It was like, oh my gosh. You're a dumb Black girl in a white school.
我不这么认为，但我不想……我不想感到自己什么都不懂，因为我在其他学校被耽误了。我不想感到自己很笨。九年级时，我确实觉得自己很笨。那种感觉就是我不懂任何事。感觉就像：噢天哪。你是白人学校里那个笨笨的黑人女孩。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
That's what it made me feel. Why should I have to suffer with that? Why couldn't you just benefit kids in another way? There is other options.
那就是它的感觉。我为什么必须忍受那个？你为什么不能用另一种方式造福孩子？还有其他选择。
I don't think you can change-- I think we have decades of people saying they were going to change a school from the outside, and I don't think-- I just don't think you do. I think New York City is full of people who write checks and people who say, I believe in equality. I mean, what we were trying to do was not just about giving some additional funds to a school. We were trying to change the power dynamics.
我不认为你能改变……我认为几十年来都有人说他们要从外部改变学校，而我不认为……我不认为你能做到。我认为纽约市充满了写支票的人，充满了说“我相信平等”的人。我的意思是，我们试图做的不仅仅是给学校提供额外资金，我们试图改变权力动态。
But that doesn't connect to why. Why did I have to be in the school?
但这和“为什么”没有联系。我为什么要在那所学校里？
Nikole says, OK, remember what happened in fourth grade when kids weren't being taught? Do you remember that? That wasn't just happening to you.
妮可说：好的，记得四年级时孩子们没有被教课的情况吗？你记得吗？那不仅仅是发生在你身上。
The only way, though, that we know that's happening is because we're in the class and we're in the school. And had we not been in the school, we wouldn't have ever known that that was happening.
然而，我们唯一知道那件事的方法是因为我们在课堂里、在学校里。如果我们没在学校里，我们永远也不会知道发生了什么。
There are ways that you could know that kind of stuff.
有些方法可以让你知道那种事。
But there aren't. And we've talked about over and over, our lives are the products of people who didn't just say, we think segregation is wrong. We think injustice is wrong. They were willing to put themselves, their families, their children on the line for that.
但并没有。我们反复讨论过，我们的生活是那些不只是说“我们认为种族隔离是错误的，我们认为不公是错误的”的人的产物。他们愿意为了那个信念把他们自己、他们的家庭、他们的孩子摆在第一线。
So you put me on the line to help a school, but it didn't work.
所以你把我摆在第一线去帮助一所学校，但没成功。
Yeah, I put you on the line in hopes of making a change, yeah.
是的，我把你摆在第一线是为了希望带来改变，是的。
But even when you knew--
但即使当你已经知道……
It's not like I never had any doubts about my choice. I did. And the only reason I'm OK with my choice now is I'm like, you're fine. I felt this was important. I tried to do the right thing.
也不是说我从未对我的选择有过怀疑。我有。我现在对我的选择感觉还好，唯一的原因是我心想：你很好。我觉得这很重要。我试着做正确的事。
And I think I'm fine because I'm in the school I am now. I feel like if I picked a different choice that you wanted me to, I don't think I would be fine.
我觉得我很好是因为我现在所在的学校。我觉得如果我选了你想要的那个，我不觉得我会很好。
OK.
好吧。
And I think this choice was good for me. And I do appreciate you for saying that.
而且我觉得这个选择对我很好。我很感激你那样说。
I think your choice is good for you as well.
我也觉得你的选择对你也很好。
Yes.
是的。
They'd done it. Nikole had committed to letting Najya have her say. She felt she owed it to her. And Nikole was committed to putting all of this out into the world. And as a final step in this whole process, she fact checked herself, and she was in for a shock. Let's give this an act, a mini act, a postscript. Act Five-- The Evidence.
她们做到了。妮可承诺让纳贾说出心里话。她觉得亏欠她的。妮可致力于把所有这些公之于众。作为整个过程的最后一步，她核实了自己的记忆，结果令她大吃一惊。让我们安排一幕，一个小幕，后记。第五幕——证据。
She was checking her memory on things as she wrote her story for The New York Times Magazine. And Nikole looked through old emails back and forth with Najya's schools, messages to principals and teachers raising concerns.
她在为《纽约时报杂志》写故事时，核实了事情的记忆。妮可查看了和纳贾学校往来的旧邮件，发给校长和老师表达担忧的信件。
And there's pages of emails. I don't even remember sending that many emails. And I'm a writer and I'm a journalist, so my emails are very detailed. Every time I'm emailing the principal, I'm quoting my daughter. I'm listing all these details, the issues we were having, not feeling like we were getting the proper response, my worries, my concerns, my, like, Najya came home and said that her teacher was gone again.
那有几页纸的邮件。我甚至不记得发过那么多邮件。我是作家、记者，所以我的邮件写得很详细。每次发给校长，我都引用我女儿的话。我列出所有细节，我们遇到的问题，没感到应有的回应，我的忧虑、关注，还有妮可回家说老师又不见了。
And this is the fourth time the teacher was gone, and there was no sub. And Najya said she had to go in the kindergarten class, but she's in second grade. And not just a record of my making complaints, but a record of non-caring-- the principal not responding, the teachers not responding over and over, and over, and over again.
这已经是老师第四次缺席了，而且没有代课老师。纳贾说她不得不去幼儿园班里，但她明明在二年级。这不仅是我投诉的记录，更是不负责任的记录——校长不回应，老师反复、反复、又反复地不回应。
And I'm in Texas that day. And I'm getting ready to go give a talk. And I'm sitting in the hotel room. And I'm just reading all of these emails.
那天我在德克萨斯州。我正准备去演讲。我坐在酒店房间里。我正在读所有这些邮件。
And it was crushing to read them. And I was like, damn, you really-- to make this work for yourself, mentally I just forgot. I had just pushed a lot of that out of my memory, I think, to be able to live with the choices we were trying to make. (TEARFULLY) And I understand my child feeling very betrayed by our choices. This is why my baby is so angry.
读到这些感到心碎。我心想：该死，你确实……为了让自己适应，我在精神上只是忘记了。我想，为了能接受我们试图做出的选择，我把很多东西赶出了记忆。（带泪地）我理解我的孩子对我们的选择感到被背叛。这就是为什么我的宝贝那么愤怒。
Did you tell her any of that?
你告诉她这些了吗？
Well, she calls me. She calls me right as I'm sitting there. I'm sitting at my desk, just going through all these emails, and I'm like-- I'm not crying, but I'm teary eyed. I'm just sitting there.
嗯，她给我打电话。她就在我坐在那儿的时候打来了。我坐在桌前，翻阅所有这些邮件，我……没哭，但眼睛湿润了。我只是坐在那儿。
So she calls me. And I pick up. And I'm trying to make my voice sound normal, but she hears that I'm upset in my voice. And she's like, what's wrong, Mommy? And I'm like, nothing. Everything's good. And she's like, what's wrong?
她打电话给我。我接了。我试着让声音听起来正常，但她听出我很心烦。她说：怎么了，妈妈？我说：没什么。一切都好。她说：到底怎么了？
And she asked me that maybe one more time. And then I just told her. I was like, I've been reading the emails from everything that was happening with your schools, and I'm sorry. And I just told her, I don't feel like you got the education you deserved, and I don't feel that I listened to you enough. I just said, I'm sorry.
她又问了一遍。然后我说了。我说：我一直在看你学校里发生的一切的邮件，对不起。我只是告诉她，我觉得你没得到应有的教育，我觉得我没足够听你的。我只是说，对不起。
What did she say?
她说什么？
She was quiet for a second. And then she told me, I'm kind of glad you're seeing this now because I don't feel like you listened to me. I don't feel like you tried to understand that. And I just apologized again, and I said, you're right.
她沉默了一会儿。然后告诉我，我很高兴你现在看到了，因为我不觉得你听过我的。我不觉得你试着理解过。我又道歉了一次，我说，你是对的。
The stakes were so high for me personally. I feel like the stakes are so high when it comes to the issue of integration and equality that I couldn't admit to her that, yes, you did bear a cost. And I don't know that we made the right choice. I don't know what the right choice would be.
对我个人而言，赌注太大了。我觉得在融合和平等问题上，赌注太高了，以至于我没法向她承认：是的，你确实付出了代价。我不知道我们是否做了正确的选择。我不知道什么是正确的选择。
I was stunned by this turn. I have never heard Nikole talk like this. I've never heard most people, my closest friends, be this truthful with themselves about their choices, especially when it comes to our kids and schools. And talking about those choices in public? Never? Why? So all of us can judge or feel smug, or angry, or vindicated, or however you have felt listening to this?
这一转折令我震惊。我从未听过妮可这样说话。我从未听过大多数人，哪怕是我最亲密的朋友，对自己的人生选择如此坦诚，尤其是关于孩子和学校。而在公开场合讨论这些选择？从来没有。为什么？这样我们大家都能评判，或者感到沾沾自喜、愤怒、被证实，或者无论你听了这些之后有什么感觉？
It's not like Nikole is the only one out here making a choice. We all live in the same world she lives in. We all live with schools that are segregated and unequal. We all make choices, imperfect, complicated choices. Nikole's just the one who's reckoning with hers, deeply and in public. And I think the less you talk about a choice, the less you scrutinize it, the easier it is to live with.
并不是只有妮可一个人在这里做选择。我们都生活在她生活的同一个世界里。我们都生活在种族隔离和不平等的学校中。我们都做出选择，不完美的、复杂的选择。妮可是唯一一个正视自己选择的人，深刻且公开。我认为，你讨论一个选择的次数越少，审视得越少，生活起来就越容易。
Nikole is in a strange, new, and disorienting place these days. She's a person who's used to making an argument, and now she's not sure what to argue for-- not just because of her experience with Najya, also because of what Nikole's seen in her reporting over the last decade. For years, Nikole's writing pushed for systemic change. In particular, she's argued that we need to integrate public schools racially and economically. And in her reporting, she's talked to so many people who put their lives into that fight, who sacrificed, made real, life-changing sacrifices that they hoped would lead to a bigger transformation.
妮可这些天处于一个奇怪、新奇且迷失的地方。她是一个习惯于提出论点的人，现在她不确定该争论什么——不仅仅是因为她和纳贾的经历，也是因为妮可过去十年在报道中所见的。多年来，妮可的写作推动了系统性变革。特别是，她主张我们需要在种族和经济上实现公立学校融合。在报道中，她与许多把生命投入到那场斗争中的人交谈过，他们做出了牺牲，真实的、改变生活的牺牲，他们希望那能带来更大的转型。
And so little has changed. Public schools are unequal and segregated as they were 10 years ago, 30 years ago, 60 years ago. If you sacrifice to make a change, but change doesn't come, all you're left with is the sacrifice.
然而变化太少了。公立学校和10年前、30年前、60年前一样不平等且处于隔离状态。如果你为了变革而牺牲，但变革没有到来，你剩下的只有牺牲。
And so what am I arguing for? I don't know anymore.
那么，我在争论什么？我不知道了。
Whoa, Nikole.
哇，妮可。
I know.
我知道。
A lot's happened.
发生了很多事。
A lot has happened. The base of the argument is that what we are doing to Black children is immoral. And that I have not wavered on, I will not waver on. I want us to understand that we choose this. I don't want us to be absolved by it, not even me. I want us to come at the end of this story sharing my sense of devastation. I feel like the culmination of all my work is I'm going to force you to bear witness to what you choose and what I choose.
确实发生了很多事。论点的基础是：我们对黑人孩子所做的在道德上是错误的。这一点我没有动摇，也不会动摇。我希望我们理解，是我们选择了这个。我不希望我们因此被赦免，包括我自己。我希望我们在故事结尾时，分享我那种毁灭感。我觉得我毕生工作的终点，就是强迫你们去见证你们所选择的，以及我所选择的。
Our program was produced and edited today by Nancy Updike with help from Ira Glass. The people who put together today's show are Cassie Howley, Adriene Lilly, Seth Lind, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Ruby Schwartz, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor, David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor, Emanuele Berry.
我们的节目由南希·厄普代克监制和编辑，艾拉·格拉斯协助。今天参与制作的人员有凯西·豪利、阿德里安·莉莉、塞斯·林德、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森、娜迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、鲁比·施瓦茨、阿莉莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。我们的主编是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。资深编辑大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。执行主编伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Nikole's article is called "In Fighting for Every Black Child, Did I Betray My Own?" And you can find it on The New York Times website. It was edited by Ilena Silverman. Special thanks today to Rachel Lissy.
妮可的文章题目是《在为每个黑人孩子奋斗时，我背叛了自己的孩子吗？》。你们可以在《纽约时报》网站上找到。它由伊莱娜·西尔弗曼编辑。特别感谢雷切尔·利西。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream an archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. And there's videos and lists of favorite shows, and tons of other stuff there too. Again, thisamericanlife.org.
我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费地在线收听超过800集的档案库。还有视频、最喜爱节目列表以及大量其他内容。再次强调，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. I'm Chana Joffe-Walt. Ira Glass will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
《美国生活》通过PRX（公共广播交易所）传送到公共广播电台。我是查娜·乔菲-沃尔特。艾拉·格拉斯下周将回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
Nikole's article is called--
妮可的文章题目是——